-A Democratic congresswoman
made a powerful speech
to her colleagues
to take action now
to solve
the cost-of-living crisis.
Also, we found out
that Donald Trump wanted
to bomb Mexico
and thought we could
pretend it wasn't us.
Two stories, one look.
The classic two-hander.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
The Republican Party remains
fully in thrall to Donald Trump,
even though he's
an aspiring authoritarian
and a crazy person.
We've known that
for a long time,
and yet somehow we keep
learning more about
just how insane Trump is
on an almost daily basis.
For example,
we found out this week
that he asked his advisers
if China had a hurricane gun
they were shooting at us
to create severe weather events.
Now, I'm assuming Trump
was thinking of a giant weapon
that could create actual
Category 5 hurricanes.
But because his brain
only works in cartoons,
there's also a chance he thought
they had a tiny handheld gun
that shot out little rain clouds
that would follow him around
wherever he went.
[As Trump] This is exactly
what they did the Daffy Duck.
We love -- we love
Daffy Duck, don't we?
We love --
You know, I once met Daffy
on the dance floor at Studio 54
back in 1982.
I met Daffy, and he said --
he came up to me
and he said something
I'll never forget.
He said, "You...
You're despicable."
And...
[ Laughter ]
And I said, "That's so true.
Daffy, that's so true."
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice] Yet somehow, that
was not the most insane thing
we learned recently,
because we also found out
from former Defense Secretary
Mark Esper
that Trump wanted to bomb Mexico
and thought we could
get away with it
because no one would know
it was us.
-Former President Trump
reportedly wanted
to launch missiles into Mexico
to destroy
the drug labs and cartels.
The allegation comes from former
Defense Secretary Mark Esper.
In a new book obtained
by The New York Times,
Esper writes Trump asked him
at least twice
about the possibility
of the airstrikes
and said no one would know
it was the U.S.
-The president pulls me aside
on at least a couple occasions
and suggests that maybe
we have the U.S. military
shoot missiles into Mexico.
-Shoot missiles into Mexico
for what?
-He would say to --
to go after the cartels.
I had to explain to him,
we can't do that.
It would violate
international law.
-You politely pushed back
on the idea.
Did President Trump really say
no one would know it was us?
-Yes. Yes.
He -- He said that,
and I just thought
it was fanciful, right?
Because of course
it would be us.
I was reluctant to tell
the story
because I think -- I thought
people won't believe this.
-No, I mean, we believe it.
Of course.
You know, we -- we believe it.
I mean, there's nothing you can
tell us about Donald Trump
that Donald Trump hasn't already
told us about Donald Trump.
The guy said with his own words
from his own mouth,
in public, on purpose,
that windmills cause cancer
and that we should inject
disinfectant into people's lungs
to cure coronavirus.
If you told me Donald Trump
asked his advisers
in an Oval Office meeting
to form an alliance
with Godzilla
to steal the hurricane gun
and find all the fraudulent
ballots smuggled in from,
I don't know, Xanadu,
I'd be like,
"Sure, yeah, whatever.
I believe it."
[ Laughter ]
But still -- still,
I kind of can't get over
the fact that Trump
thought we could bomb Mexico
without anyone knowing
it was us.
Imagine you're Mexico.
The U.S. just had an election
where they chose
a visibly insane game show host
who said horrible things
about Mexicans,
and suddenly missiles
start raining down on you.
Would you be mystified?
"Who's shooting these
Patriot missiles at us?
Did someone say something
that upset Costa Rica?"
So obviously it's critical
that we as a nation
do everything in our power
to prevent this obviously
unhinged demagogue
and his allies
in the Republican Party
from regaining power.
And that, unfortunately,
is where the Democrats come in.
Oof!
It's like if you yelled,
"Avengers assemble!"
and only Hawkeye showed up.
[ Laughter ]
"And, uh, ehh...
FYI -- I did forget
my arrows, guys.
It's gonna be the classic
Hawkeye punches."
If you've been paying any
attention at all to politics,
you know that Democrats
are in dire straits right now.
You don't need a poll
to tell you that.
All you have to do is watch
any Joe Biden press conference
with the sound off.
He's always doing that thing
where he leans over the podium
like every question
is causing him physical pain.
He looks like --
looks like one
of Trump's advisers
after Trump asked about
the hurricane gun again.
[ Laughter ]
"Yeah, they, uh...
They don't got
one of those, boss."
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, things are bad
for Democrats.
And that's not just me
saying that.
Take congresswoman
and progressive rising star
Katie Porter,
who's perhaps best known
for using congressional hearings
to grill some of the nation's
most powerful figures,
from bankers to pharma CEOs
to oil executives,
using props like a whiteboard
where she calculates the cost of
living for a typical bank teller
or a big sign called
Financial Services Bingo.
Everyone in Congress is so old,
she had to use bingo
to get their attention.
"Quiet! Quiet!
She's calling out numbers!"
Porter once even participated
in a hearing
with oil execs via Zoom
from her house
where she used bags of rice
in the trunk of her car
to help visualize
how much public land
oil companies could use
for drilling,
given that oil companies
were all opposed to a pause
on new federal drilling leases
on public lands.
-How many acres of public land
are already leased
by fossil fuel companies
and not even used yet?
-I think you have
a fundamental misunderstanding
as to how this process works
and the time and resources --
-Reclaiming my time.
Reclaiming my time.
The answer is
13.9 million acres.
To visualize
how much land that is,
if each grain of rice
were one acre,
that would be
479 pounds of rice.
The American Petroleum Institute
even opposed
pausing more leasing
on our lands,
they even sued to stop it,
because apparently this acreage
wasn't enough.
Ms. Watkins,
do you support a pause on new
federal oil and gas leases?
-No, I do not,
'cause I think it's important --
-You already have
13.9 million acres.
This is equivalent to Maryland
and New Jersey combined.
How much more do you need?
-First of all, I love
the dramatic reveal
when the automatic door
slowly opens.
I've never been so excited
to see what's
in the trunk of a minivan.
Usually when someone's opening
the trunk of a car like that,
it's a mobster
showing you a dead body.
"Yeah, the minivan's great
'cause the back seats lift
right out.
I can get, like,
five snitches in here.
Used to have to take
a bunch of trips."
[ Laughter ]
It was such an effective
visual metaphor.
If she had a music budget,
she could have added the score
from "2001: A Space Odyssey."
[ "Also Sprach Zarathustra"
plays ]
♪♪
I also love when
they cut back to her
and she's just standing there
stone-faced,
pouring out a bag of rice
like it's some sort of
grain-based interrogation.
The oil execs must have been
[bleep] their pants.
"Tell me what I want to know,
or you can say goodbye
to your precious Rice-A-Roni."
"Please, God,
not the San Francisco treat!"
So, that --
that's Katie Porter.
She's a rising star
in the Democratic Party,
and deservedly so.
And now she is warning
her fellow Democrats
about the peril
they face in the midterms
unless they do something real
to improve people's lives.
According to Politico,
Porter issued a wake-up call
to her fellow
congressional Democrats
when she gave
an emotional speech
about how inflation has been
hitting her family for months
during a private
House Democratic Caucus
meeting last week.
She said it seemed like
the first time the personal toll
of high consumer prices
had sunk in
for some lawmakers in the room.
Porter told Politico, "I had
a colleague mention to me,
'We're not seeing it
in the polls.'"
That's because
inflation is so bad,
it's just screwing up
the poll results.
[ Laughter ]
And just to be clear,
I'm not saying inflation
is somehow the Democrats' fault.
They just happen to be
in charge now,
so it's on them to do
something about it.
But obviously, there are lots
of causes for rising costs,
including corporate greed,
supply chain problems
caused by a pandemic
Trump let spiral out of control
because he thought
it was a hoax,
which is why it's so craven
and disingenuous
when Republicans
shamelessly tweet
about how low gas prices
were under Trump.
Like when Congressman
Jim Jordan tweeted...
Yeah, man. I also remember
that no one was buying gas
because we were all trapped
in our homes,
hiding from a deadly
respiratory disease
your guy thought could be cured
by chugging a bottle of Windex.
Fuel prices are based,
among other things,
on supply and demand.
And since no one
was traveling anywhere,
meaning there were fewer cars on
the road and planes in the sky,
gas was cheap as [bleep].
It's the same reason
flat-screen TVs are cheap now,
because you can watch "Avatar 2"
on your [bleep] phone.
By the way, I'm told
you gotta see it that way.
[ Laughter ]
That's the way
to see "Avatar 2,"
just with a phone
super close to your face.
And don't put in EarPods.
Let everybody hear it.
So, Republicans are obviously
lying when they pretend to care
about the cost of living,
and they have no plan whatsoever
to improve the lives
of working people.
In fact, we found out today that
supposed pro-worker populist
Donald Trump colluded
with meat processors
to keep their factories open
even as COVID was ravaging
their workers.
So Republicans clearly don't
care about the working class.
They're much more focused
on canceling Mickey Mouse
for being too woke.
Democrats have given voters
so many reasons
Republicans are insane,
they're probably like...
-How much more do you need?
-But still...
Still, it is on Democrats
to do something
to improve people's lives,
like extend the massively
popular child tax credit
or invest directly
in green infrastructure,
forgive student loan debt,
or expand healthcare.
And look, I get it.
Joe Manchin is a giant ass-ache.
The dude rakes in cash
from fossil fuels,
drives a Maserati and lives
on a yacht called Almost Heaven,
which sounds less like
the name of a yacht
and more like the title
of an early-2000s rom-com
starring Ryan Reynolds
and Mandy Moore.
Not my favorite movie,
but I watched it on an airplane
once and I cried so hard
an air marshal had to tell me
to shut the [bleep] up.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause I guess feeling something
is against the law!
[ Laughter ]
Manchin has been
stringing Democrats along
for over a year now, so
Democrats just have to
call his bluff and say,
"What will you accept?
We will pass it."
Which is why it's frustrating
to read stuff like this
in The Atlantic this week --
What? Why?
Look, we all know Manchin sucks
and he's gonna drag his heels,
but Chuck Schumer,
what are you waiting for?
What's the problem here?
Are your glasses too far
down your nose to read?
Does he realize
glasses only work
if they're in front
of your eyes?
Would you -- would you like
another pair of glasses
to help find your glasses?
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, look at that.
They were way down
at the end of my nose.
No wonder I couldn't govern."
Just call --
call Manchin's bluff
and ask him what he wants.
If Manchin's bull[bleep]
and his answer is actually
that he's opposed to everything,
which is very possible,
then at least we'll know
and we can move on.
It's like when you're trying
to find something on TV
to watch with your partner.
How about "Ozark"? Too dark.
How about "Better Call Saul"?
Too slow?
At some point you just got
to hand over the remote and say,
"Okay, you pick something."
And look, you'll probably end up
watching something called
"The Teakettle Murders
on BritBox with the subtitles on
because everyone talks
like this --
[ British accent ]
[ Laughter ]
But at least you're
watching something.
And believe me, I know it sucks
that this dude
gets to call the shots.
I'd much rather live in a world
where the deciding vote
was Katie Porter
instead of Joe Manchin.
But we do not live
in that world.
We live in a world where
two obstructionist centrists
are stopping the Democrats
from delivering on their agenda
while an unhinged
Republican Party
remains laser-focused
on dismantling democracy
and installing an authoritarian
demagogue in power.
Republicans are so full of it,
you'd think they just ate...
-479 pounds of rice.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
-God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.